today on the matt wall show riots have
made their way to amish country now this
time blm and antifa are tearing the city
of lancaster apart because a
knife-wielding maniac
got shot while trying to stab a police
officer to death
this somehow is racism we're told also
two police officers in la fall victim to
an attempted assassination
um how much responsibility do joe biden
and the democrats bear for that
um and in our daily cancellation i will
be canceling
the black national anthem black national
anthem is canceled
um and uh that was played before every
nfl game this weekend but it is
cancelled
all of that on the way but first a
couple of brief notes first of all if
you watch this podcast on youtube you
should know that
on september 28th it will be moving from
the daily wire channel to be available
exclusively
on my personal youtube channel pretty
easy to find just youtube.com
matt walsh uh matt walsh channel that's
all you gotta find or you can
go to the link in the description i'm
also making a lot of new content that
you can
only find on on my channel so subscribe
to my youtube channel
make sure to ring the bell to uh make
sure you never miss out on a new video
i'm gonna have to become like every
other youtuber now constantly telling
you to
hit that like button and subscribe but
these are necessary sacrifices so make
sure you go
right now and subscribe to that also i
want to tell you before we get going
today that the show is brought to you by
bambi um and you know any any
business owner knows that hr issues can
absolutely kill you if you want to have
a successful business
you got to have your hr house in order
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
these are all just some some of the
hurdles that you face and hr managing
manager salaries are not cheap you know
an average of seventy thousand dollars a
year you're going to spend
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated hr
manager
craft hr policy maintain your compliance
all for just 99
a month with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is avail
available by phone email
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations
they customize the policies to fit your
business and
uh they help manage your employees
day-to-day
all for just 99 a month if you're not a
huge company
then spending tons of time and money on
hr stuff is not ideal
it's not what you want so why do that
you got to get bambi
go to bambi.com walsh right now to
schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi.com spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com all right
now um most people i think probably have
never heard of
lancaster um those who are familiar with
it know that it is
amish country nestled in the rural part
of southern pennsylvania
lancaster is home to one of the largest
amish communities in america that was
its claim to fame
but even amish lancaster about as far
geographically and culturally from
portland or seattle as you can get
is not uh is not safe from the morally
deranged thugs of antifa and blm
rioters descended on the city last night
ostensibly in protest
of the death of a man named ricardo
munoz
we'll talk about the specifics of that
case in just a moment but first
let's take a look at some of the action
in amish land
from last night watch this
[Music]
they're masking up
[Music]
is
back
oh
yes that is what collective madness
looks like
there's nothing coherent being said here
no message no reason no point
just hate aggression and anger directed
outwards at
everyone and everything these these are
people with the emotional intelligence
of
infants and the intellectual
intelligence of
sea sponges and that becomes even
clearer when you
see the supposed reason for this latest
bout of lunacy and chaos
the 27 year old munoz was confronted by
police after his sister called 911 to
report that her brother was getting
aggressive with their mother
and trying to break into her house in
the body cam you can see a woman
flee terrified fired from the house as
the police arrive
and then munoz comes charging out with a
knife
watch coming your way
where'd he go
get back
as you can see there munoz is chasing
the officer literally waving a
butcher's knife in the air like some
kind of horror movie villain
he was mere moments from getting close
enough to sink the blade into the
officer when he was shot
this is a this is about as justified as
a police shooting can possibly get
yet blm still protests weeping and
wailing and gnashing their teeth
pretending to be distraught that this
noble gentleman is no longer with us
as it happens ricardo munoz is the
second blm martyr in a row
after jacob blake to be shot after
getting the cops called on him
by uh by a woman that he was harassing
and threatening the other two blm
martyrs from this summer
george floyd and rachard brooks also had
histories of abusing and tormenting
women
um these are the men that blm wants us
to honor and celebrate
abusers criminals sociopaths appropriate
mascots i suppose for one of the most
morally degenerate political movements
in american history rarely in this
country have we ever
seen a group that is so cartoonishly and
absolutely evil
with no redeeming qualities and nothing
to be said in its favor at all
we should be very clear about this blm
has
no valid points nothing to offer nothing
to say
no reason to take them seriously they
should not be listened to or respected
they deserve scorn and only scorn
even now i still hear people who know
better claim that blm is at least
calling attention to important issues no
they aren't
the only issue that blm is calling
attention to is its own
moral vacuousness so don't try to find
something salvageable in this heap there
is nothing to find
these are bad people doing bad things
for bad reasons
and if rioting an amish country because
a cop shot a man who was moments away
from stabbing him with a butcher's knife
is not enough to convince you of that
fact then i don't know what will
meanwhile also this weekend two los
angeles county sheriff's deputies were
critically injured in an assassination
attempt
uh video which you can see here shows
someone walk up to the two officers as
they're sitting in their police cruiser
and open fire through the window the
victims are are both
new to the force sworn in just over a
year ago one is a 31 year old mother the
other 24 year old man
in a screenshot from the video you can
see the female officer who had been shot
in the jaw
helping to apply a tourniquet to her
partner now this is what heroism looks
like it doesn't it doesn't look like
jacob blake or ricardo muniz
these are real heroes fortunately though
they're not
martyrs because they are both expected
to survive thank god
now democrats like joe biden came out
uh to offer their weak condemnations of
the attack
here's biden he says this cold-blooded
shooting is unconscionable and the
perpetrator must be brought to justice
violence of any kind is wrong those who
commit it should be
caught and punished jill and i are
keeping the deputies and their loved
ones in our prayers and in our hearts
praying for their full recovery um then
camille harris said doug and i are
keeping the two los angeles
county sheriff's deputies in our hearts
as they currently fight for their lives
after a horrific attack
the perpetrator must be brought to
justice adam schiff chimed in saying
praying for the two deputies who were
shot in an apparent ambush
and thinking of their loved ones tonight
every day law enforcement officers put
themselves at risk
to protect our community uh i hope the
perpetrator of this cowardly attack can
be quickly brought to justice
yeah okay now i hope this doesn't sound
ungracious
but let me just say to the democrats
issuing their thoughts and prayers and
condemnations
shut up you gutless snakes
you damned hypocrites you disgusting
frauds you repulsive phonies
you're not fooling anyone you democrats
along with your
servants in the media and be in your blm
constituency
you are all directly responsible for
this you are responsible for those cops
being shot
just as you're responsible for so much
of the violence against police that
we've seen over the summer
and over the past several years let's
not forget about the five cops that were
executed in dallas during a
blm rally a few years ago and you will
be responsible for the cops that are
attacked and assassinated in the future
and there will be more
you may not pull the trigger but you
carry an equal moral guilt
you cannot distance yourself from this
when cops start
dying you cannot pretend to be shocked
or surprised or horrified
they are reaping what you have sowed
this is your fault this is on you
when you in a position of power and
authority however unearned that power
and authority may be
go around telling wild fables about
racist police hunting and killing
innocent black people
and then those racist those racist
hunters wind up dead or in the hospital
with a bullet wound to the jaw
you cannot pretend that you're innocent
you know exactly what you're doing
there is a there is a direct correlation
here
so let's not let's not uh let's not
dance around this at all
but you know of course whoever pulls the
trigger they're 100 responsible
but you in a position of authority by
encouraging that
you are also 100 responsible for that
and they know what they're doing what do
you think's going to happen
when you go around saying that they're
that the the cops are a danger they need
to be potentially defunded or whatever
they're in danger they're they're
hunting and they're killing black people
um there's a you know there's an
epidemic there's a crisis of this
happening in the country
there isn't it's a lie and you know it
now if you're just one of these morons
on the street you might not know it
because you're so
damn stupid um and you haven't thought
critically about
any of the issues that you're currently
you know burning police cars over you
haven't thought critically about any of
them
but these democrats joe biden the rest
he knows
he knows well maybe not joe biden i
don't know what he knows anymore i'm not
even sure what he's conscious of but
camila harris let's just say her she
knows okay
this is somebody who is in law
enforcement on some level
so she knows it's not true there's an
epidemic of police officers killing
innocent people no there
isn't not even close this is completely
and totally
made up it's not happening so when you
tell a made-up story
police officers doing this and then and
then next thing you know they're getting
shot randomly as they sit and
apparently not so randomly actually as
they sit in their police cruisers yes
your response
it would be just like if i decided you
know that um
i really don't like plumbers and so i'm
going to dedicate
many of my shows to telling you how evil
plumbers are and i'm going to make up
stories about plumbers and tell you that
you know when plumbers when they come to
your house they're not really
fixing the toilet they're you know
they're installing cameras in your
in your in your bathroom because they're
a bunch of perverts i i start making up
all these
wild just out of whole cloth i'm just
making up stories about plumbers because
i have a i have a problem with them
and if i do that for weeks on end
and then next thing you know um there's
a rash of plumbers
getting killed or beat up can i really
sit here and say well i had no idea
don't look at me
what's i'm just sharing my opinion it's
not my fault
no either my
intention was to get the plumbers beat
up or
i had some other intention and i didn't
give a damn whether they were
attacked or not now it comes to these
democrats like biden and harris and the
rest of them
they have other intentions okay they
have they have a political goal
and they just don't care if it gets
police officers shot doesn't make a
difference to them
because they're soulless but it's it's
politically useful for them to go with
this
made-up ridiculous fable about police
officers
shooting innocent uh black people so
yes a hundred percent responsible and i
think we have to be totally clear about
that
let's go to our um five headlines
[Music]
you know winter is uh fast approaching i
hate to say
and that's why you want to get outside
spend as much time outdoors as you
possibly can especially as we get into
the fall okay this is when
fall is objectively the best season
there's no discussion to be had about
that
so that's what you need rad power bikes
for whether you want a new way to get
around town or out in nature even with
the kids in tow
you've got to try rad power bikes across
between a traditional bike and a moped
but it doesn't require a special
driver's license like a moped would you
can go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling
so you can get out and about without
getting all sweaty they're great for
commuting getting out on the trail
hauling groceries transporting your kids
on the back
rad power bikes are affordable most
e-bikes are in the 3 000
range rad power bikes though just 9.99
and and most are under 1500 so you're
gonna get them for a lot cheaper
great product though uh and this is you
know what it's
practical but it's also fun so you got
the practicality and the fun
rad power bikes offers flexible
financing for as low as zero percent apr
and now for a limited time
get a free accessory value of uh valued
at up to 100
with the purchase of a bike that's right
free accessory free gift of
up to a hundred dollars in value and
free shipping to the lower 48 states to
get this special offer text the word
bike
to 64 000 that's bike to 64 000 text
bike
to 64 000. okay
um this is why i've always said that the
book if you give a mouse a cookie
is one of the most prophetic works of
literature i think
in of our time in american history
certainly um
there's a great example right here the
nfl engaged in um
all kinds of racially woke pageantry
over the weekend as the the nfl season
started
and we'll talk more about that in the
daily cancellation but
uh you know you thought colin kaepernick
i mean this is all being done for his
benefit
and and for the people that support him
but he was not impressed he sent out a
tweet after all of this and he said um
well the nfl runs propaganda about how
much they care about black life
they are still actively blackballing
eric reid for fighting for the black
community eric set two franchise records
last year
and is one of the best defensive players
in the league so it's one of his buddies
who doesn't have a job yet in nfl
a free agent and uh and he's upset about
that so
now first of all let me say i agree with
the first few words of what
what colin kaepernick said and that's
the most i'll ever agree with him so
we've got the first few words of that
statement in common he says the nfl is
running propaganda you're right it is
propaganda
the rest of it not so much um
but he's not satisfied and the sjws
they're never satisfied
that's why i say if you give a mouse a
cookie okay re
read that that children's books one of
my favorite books as a kid
but i didn't realize all the depth of
meaning in this book
and if you're not familiar with it and
if you give a mouse a cookie
it's all about this kid who's got a
mouse in the house and the mouse wants a
cookie
and he says okay i'll give you the
cookie but next thing you know what is
the mouse when he wants a napkin
and then he wants milk and then he wants
uh i don't know
carrots and then he wants every every
last thing
next thing you know he's eaten the
entire house and everything in it and
the child is left destitute and cold on
the street that's that's my memory of
the book anyway
i might be getting that slightly wrong
but the point is you get you give
you satiate with just one thing and then
it's no i need something else and
something else and something else and
something else
and that's the way it works with the
left you give them the one thing they
want
and now no now we need more and here's
the next thing here's the next thing
here's the next thing
maybe in fact instead of making my my
very intelligent literary reference here
uh maybe a better analogy would be like
the mob
okay it's it's sort of like with the mob
where you you know they they
you you you cut a deal with them you
think it's one thing and then you'll be
done
and then uh and then they come back and
they want more they don't get out of
your life at least
based on the movies that's how it seems
to go so take that
take whichever analogy you want if you
give a mouse a cookie
or a mafia movies that's as intelligent
as it gets on this show
let's go uh to number two the daily wire
reports um it says even though the
backlash against netflix's cuties was
largely bipartisan a new op-ed in slate
has put the blame squarely on the
shoulders of conservatives according to
sam adams
uh conservatives have a creepy obsession
with the new french film which has been
accused of indefensibly sexualizing 11
year old girls in the name of artistry
uh adams wrote quote the movie finds
itself at the toxic intersection
of q anon delusion and right wing moral
panic with a smattering of leftist
outrage on the side
breitbart has posted about the movie a
half dozen times in the past two days
singling out critics who praised the
film several of whom have received death
threats
and have been harassed off of social
media and thursday night tucker carlson
made it a centerpiece of his show
accusing a non-specific
they behind the movie of wanting to
destroy young girls
then it goes on the daily wire report
adams argued that the critics of the
movie have not actually seen it
choosing instead to go off of the
marketing materials and viral clips
online addressing those who would say
that cuties pushes
softcore child pornography adams argued
that intent
matters in this case by definition
pornography requires intent and whether
or not
the director succeeded at her intent is
uh
her unless whether or not she succeeded
her intent is clear the movie's
protagonist amy is an 11 year old
bouncing between
the repressive culture of her
conservative islamic upbringing where
she has warned that evil
shows itself in the scantily clad women
and the hyper-sexualized environment of
western culture where images of adult
women doing strip club gyrations are
emulated by tweens on social media
the movie presents those images in order
to critique them
uh even if all of that was true
the fact that it tells you everything
you need to know that this guy doesn't
even doesn't even see a problem with
that
okay so according to him the movie is
presenting
uh sort of traditional religious culture
as equally
as evil as pedophilic
uh sexualization of children for him he
sees them as both just as bad
he's putting them on the same moral
playing field so
that would be bad enough as it is but
it's also i think uh just not true and
this idea that intent doesn't matter in
fact
somebody made an interesting point on
twitter i don't remember who it was
but made an interesting point about you
know on the left
they usually tell us intent doesn't
matter at all
so for example if somebody says the n
word
even if they're just and it's a white
person of course white person says the n
word
even if they're just quoting someone
else
if there's there's there's no racial uh
intent at all
there's no racist intent at all even if
they're simply quoting or they're
singing along to a song where it's used
a rap song or something um we're told
that
intent makes no difference that's racist
even if you didn't mean it in a race
this way it is racist it's horrible it's
the worst thing that you can ever do
that's what we're told and there are
many examples of this on the left
where usually they say intent doesn't
matter
and but they have it exactly backwards
because in most of the cases where they
say intent doesn't matter
in those kinds of cases of course intent
matters if if you're just
saying something if you're saying words
then yes when it comes to the
words you say intent is everything
i can't even begin to be offended by the
words you say if i'm even inclined to be
offended by words in the first place
until i know why you said them because
that's that's really all that matters
is what you meant when you said it now
when it comes to actually to taking
actual
children and putting them in these
sexually compromised
and vulnerable positions and sexualizing
them on camera and having them simulate
sex acts through dance on camera
and you know the camera's zooming in on
various body parts and everything
with something like that intent does not
matter
because the act itself
is by definition sexualization
you are by definition sexualizing a
child
the reason why you're sexually
sexualizing a child
doesn't matter i don't see that making
any moral difference whatsoever
so on one hand you have words just words
intent there is everything on the other
hand you have
you are taking actual children this
isn't like a book
where they're telling a story about this
happening that would be totally
different
but these are real children who you have
taken and put them in these positions
on camera and you're profiting off of it
so the left has everything upside down
and backwards as usual
number three donald trump um said that
he
is willing to do a debate with joe biden
moderated by joe rogan
so tim kennedy tweeted out said on my
podcast with joe rogan he offered to
moderate a debate between joe biden and
donald trump it would be four hours with
no live audience
just the two candidates cameras and
their vision for how to move the country
forward
who wants this and donald trump
responded i do
now this is never going to happen but i
think it's just there really isn't any
argument
there isn't any good argument against us
i think it's very clear this would be
the best whether it's joe rogan or
somebody else
you know something like that where it's
a lengthy discussion where the moderator
is not interfering that much and just
letting the two people
have a conversation i guess what i'm
saying is a debate that's actually a
debate can you imagine that
that would obviously be far superior to
the to the
hyper overly moderated uh
shows that we normally get and we'll get
certainly this time
if there is a debate at all but i think
that would be great number four i
mentioned earlier that blm is one of the
most morally deranged political
movements in american history
well here's more evidence if you needed
it for that claim i didn't have time to
play this during the opening
but after those two officers were shot
in los angeles
a witness recorded a video with his
live and honest reaction and it is
it is something watch just heard the
police oh
they just aired the police on this the
only
that's crazy they just got aired out
somebody ran up on the car and bust on
it
right through the window in the face and
on
it's a wrap now let's remember here this
is a woman
and a man uh both shot you know woman
shot in the face
and lying on the ground and this guy is
he loves it leave aside the fact that
this guy apparently only knows about six
words and he just keeps repeating them
over and over again
um but he thinks it's great he's
laughing hysterically
and there are other people around too
who seem to be very impressed with this
just imagine that i i really think about
it because we get so desensitized
to this sort of thing for seeing these
sorts of videos so often but
think about you somebody on the scene
sees a woman get shot in the face in
real time
and she's bleeding on the ground and
you're laughing about it
you would think even if you're a
horrible person even even
the average horrible person would at
least be so shocked
and surprised by that and disturbed by
the blood and everything that they would
probably react in a in a
relatively human way so think about how
utterly soulless you have to be to not
even have that
basic human visceral gut level reaction
to witnessing something like that
and the point is this is the kind of
mentality and
attitude that police officers in the
city especially a city like los angeles
encounter every day i mean they're
dealing with criminals
who um i don't know if this guy's a
criminal or not certainly wouldn't
surprise me given how uh given how he
apparently feels about
given the fact that he's he's a big fan
of crime it seems he's very impressed
with it
but um they they are dealing with with
criminals who
are just total sociopaths and
uh think that violence is funny don't
don't value human life for all the stuff
about black lives matter
yes it does all all lives matter uh but
i think you see why um
some of the blm activists react to
all lives matter they get very upset
about that because they they really
don't think that all lives matter
the people there and that and that's a
video
they just they just don't believe they
don't see that that life matters at all
then you're a police officer and you're
coming up against this mentality every
single day
all right five finally uh joe biden was
was speaking over the weekend
uh gave a speech and this is part of the
speech that i thought was
this part here was pretty pretty
riveting watch what makes his wild
claims and hopes
he now hopes we don't notice what he
said or won't remember
and when he does follow through or
doesn't do
would follow through the exact opposite
what makes his wild claims and hopes
he now hopes we don't notice what he
said or won't remember and when
he does follow through or doesn't do
when follow through
the exact opposite that's what he just
heard there
you know biden when he speaks he has
this remarkable ability to make me
wonder if maybe i'm the one who had the
stroke
but no i'm pretty sure it was just him
i'm pretty sure he was the one but still
it does it it does have this
disassociative sort of effect where you
start to question your own sanity
we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second but before
we do
you know uh the lockdowns have just been
crushing businesses and
have been horrible for the economy uh
lots of very sad tales of business
owners
losing their businesses or finding
themselves in dire straits
um but the god king of the daily wire
jeremy boring
he has been able to lead the daily wire
through
this this uh uh environment
and uh we've been you know more
successful at the end of it
and so that's why this october the daily
wire guide king jeremy boring is going
to be presenting alongside an incredibly
successful group of business owners at
expert ownership live a virtual
conference about leading through
crisis the conference features a lineup
of speakers like world-renowned
leadership author
john maxwell the founders of duck
commander and otterbox the
bennenbrothers
and many others who can relate to what
entrepreneurs and leaders are going
through right now they'll share their
stories
about their own businesses their own
startup journeys the tough times that
come with any company
and how they were able to come out even
stronger on the other side
the best part if you go to expert
ownership live dot com slash walsh right
now you'll be able to register for only
97 bucks with an opportunity to buy a
second ticket for a friend
half off you don't want to miss this you
don't want to miss the
the wisdom and advice you're going to
get so go to expert ownership live
dot com walls to register for only 97
for a limited time only
that's expert ownership live dot com
walsh
today for our daily cancellation i will
be canceling the so-called black
national anthem now if you watch
football mainly to be
enlightened by socially conscious
symbolism and random gestures to social
justice then you were thrilled by how
the nfl season started this weekend
it had already been announced that every
stadium would have the words end
racism spray painted onto the field if
that was not enough in itself to heal
our collective wounds and bring about
global peace and prosperity
then hopefully the players wearing the
names of alleged police brutality
victims on their helmets would seal the
deal
but what if the whole population of the
world was still not
clasping hands and looking softly into
one another's eyes
after a bunch of millionaires ran around
a football field
with names like jacob blake and accused
rapist and serial abuser
and rachard brooks a man who violently
assaulted a police officer after passing
out drunk behind the wheel of a car
uh taped to their helmets you know what
if what if even that wasn't enough well
then surely
the players kneeling or sitting or
raising their fist or dancing the
macarena or performing whatever other
random choreography
during the national anthem would do the
job
but if somehow all of those measures
still are insufficient in the struggle
to establish a new utopia
then the nfl had one more ace up its
sleeve
the black national anthem before
each week one game a song which was
penned in 1899 by james weldon johnson
it's called lift every voice and sing
now dubbed the black national anthem
uh this song was was performed teams had
various approaches to the song
but some were not shy at all about
paying more reverence to the black
national anthem
than the national national anthem my
hometown baltimore ravens i'm afraid to
say
mostly knelt or sat during the real the
real anthem but stood at attention
across the goal line
for lift every voice this was an odd
choice
considering what we've been told for
years about how the kneeling
is a protest against police brutality
not a protest
against the anthem or the flag haven't
we been told that
if that's the case why didn't they kneel
during the so-called
black national anthem too does their
concern for police brutality magically
dissipate as soon as the words
the land of the free and home of the
brave are sung are they less worried
about the
imaginary scourge of racist police
hunting black men
while lift every voice is playing i mean
i i just don't understand if that's what
you're protesting why wouldn't you still
be doing the protest during that song if
the national anthem was officially
abolished and replaced by this other
song
would the players decide that racial
injustice is no longer a problem
do they actually think that racial
injustice is caused by the national
anthem
these are the questions that inevitably
arise and i suspect we will never be
given any sort of
coherent answer to them here's another
question
what the hell does the black national
anthem even mean
national anthems are you may have
guessed this from the name
anthems for the nation they are
supposed to be uplifting and in
spiriting songs
for about and to a whole nation of
people
until recently we always stood together
when it was played
as a symbol of our national unity this
is the point that's been entirely lost
in all the debate over the anthem
protest
standing for the anthem is actually not
primarily a show of respect for the
military
or the founding fathers or the
constitution or whatever else
but it's a sign of unity and commonality
among the people of america
it's something we do or used to do for
each other
not for the government or even the flag
and that's why it never made sense to
kneel during the anthem as a statement
against police brutality
the anthem has nothing to do with the
police except that police officers are
americans too
and and that's what we're all supposed
to be when the anthem plays
americans together what about the black
national anthem what purpose does it
serve
what country is it an anthem two there
is no black nation
no black landia or blacktopia there is
no white landia or whitetopia either
there are countries populated mainly by
white people and
and countries populated mainly by black
people but black itself
is not a nation and neither is white
to have a national anthem two or about
or for a particular
skin pigmentation is to begin with
completely nonsensical
national anthems by definition are for
everyone in the nation
a national anthem for 13 percent of the
population is not a national anthem at
all
it's as if the mpaa combined its g and r
movie ratings
to come up with gr general restricted if
it's for general audiences
it's not restricted if it's restricted
it's not for general audiences
in the same way if the black national
anthem is a national anthem it isn't
just for black people if it is just for
black people then it's not a national
anthem it cannot be both
it cannot be for one race and also be
national
aside from the logical problems the
whole idea of playing an anthem
four or two a certain race is morally
grotesque
it's just more segregation and division
in a time when exactly the opposite is
required
our country does not need more singling
out of certain races
more lines drawn more attention called
to our differences
there's quite enough of that already
what we need is unity
national unity under a national flag and
anthem now i don't know if we can
actually have that sort of unity
now but i do know that the kind of
segregated and racialized pageant
pageantry we saw from the nfl this
weekend
certainly is not helping matters and
something tells me
it isn't supposed to
so the black national anthem is canceled
but the good thing is we still have the
national anthem
it's for everybody okay it's not the
white national anthem it's for everyone
who's an american and that's the point
and that's why we stand it is an act of
unity
together
and uh we'll leave it there for the day
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton